- Where are our
eyeballs and ears going?
That to me is the thing that
I'm completely obsessed
with right now.
Where are we spending our time.
It's attention.
Definitely caught my attention.
I'm paying very close attention.
Has really caught
my attention
but that would have
caught my attention.
Caught my attention.
Marco Polo caught my attention.
That's where Musical.ly
caught my attention.
Snapchat caught my attention.
What I think I'm really
good at buying and selling.
I did that with stuff my
whole life, now I do it with
people's attention and the
end consumer's attention.
So when people were listening to
the radio people that wanted
to sell stuff, marketers,
realized they're paying
attention to the radio.
Why don't I stop what they're
listening to and because they're
baseball fans let me
sell them this beer?
And tell them why we're the best
beer ever and interrupt them.
That process, my friends,
has gone on forever and ever.
You can go back to
the caves, right?
Here's a cave, I use it because
I don't want to get eaten by a
dinosaur and some dude wants to
sell me a new club and he drew
some shit in there to sell me.
So while my attention was here
staying away from the dinosaurs,
maybe I need a new club.
That long and that forever.
Wherever there are people paying
attention to something marketers
like myself want to ruin it.
(light music)